mary wants me to sit down I want to
stand up
I have this urge to move around there's
so much energy in this room tonight
today and thank you Tom so much for
setting the stage of what was going on
in the 60s is not a remarkable story of
what where we were the way we were back
then and some of you in the audience
remember this some of you remember it
from our history that you helped write
and that some of us have written Tom and
I go way back we met a lot of different
times in Washington working through
these national organizations and
brainstorming about what next to do so I
really enjoy the fact that Tom came to
join us today I wanted to we each have
ten minutes according to Mary so we can
either talk very fast or leave out a lot
of things and I think we'll leave out a
lot of things and focus on what we think
are the important most important things
to tell you today the first thing I'd
like to do those to get you up out of
your feet and I'll tell you why Mary
mentioned how important Jack Cole is and
was to this program I'd like to second
that and recognize him since this is
being videotaped let's all stand up and
gave him a standing ovation jackhole
so how and why did Yale start a PA
program you've heard some of the
interesting models and the history from
several other institutions at Yale it
was the idea came in the following
manner dr. Cole came to be the new head
of surgery here in 1969 and he had
several priorities for his department
one of which was to look at emergency
medicine and trauma and accidents as a
major focus of his department and the
reason he picked that was because in
addition to all the other things that
Tom alluded to was going on in the in
the 60s another thing that was neglected
another dimension of the medical scene
that was neglected was the problem of
accidents and trauma the National
Academy of Sciences in 1966 after a lot
of study came up with a report which
called accidents the neglected disease
of society and said someone needs to
deal with the fact that people are dying
in our highways they're dying on our
streets and we are not responding
effectively we learn from Vietnam that
if you go to the accident scene you can
do some very important life-saving
measures you don't wait until the
patient is brought back to the military
hospital or in the civilian sector to a
major medical center could some of these
same principles be applied to our
civilian sector dr. Cole went to the
Commonwealth Fund of New York and the
Commonwealth Fund is a very important
private foundation philanthropy and
health they have endowed a lot of things
here as you saw yesterday when we met
after the white coat ceremony the place
where we met Harkness pavilion was
endowed by the Commonwealth Fund because
the Harkness family is a Yale family and
has done much to help foster health care
in this country through the Commonwealth
Fund into other ways so he went to the
Commonwealth Fund and said I'd like to
do something in my department surgery to
deal with accidental injury and
disability got a 1 million dollar grant
from the Commonwealth Fund which back
then was real money it would be like a
trillion dollars now and set forth to
look at the response to accidents from a
systems point of view enter Blair Sadler
by much younger brother and we're having
a birthday in about two days if anybody
can guess which one it is there'll be a
special treat you'll get an extra CM e
point on your sheet at the end of the
day if you don't get it right you'll get
to see any points actually and if Blair
and I had always been interested Blair
being a lawyer we were in Philadelphia
be finishing my medical training Blair
his legal training were fascinated by
issues at the interface of law and
medicine the Good Samaritan issue
definition of death use of human beings
and medical research on and on and on
and we thought if we could find a way to
work together and also satisfy our
military obligation at a time when the
Vietnam War was escalating this is 1967
how many here we're alive in 1967
it's not just the year in the history
books so we were fortunate to get an
opportunity to go to the NIH and work as
a medical legal blob of twin dhum on
health law problems and the first thing
they told us about that they wanted us
to work on was organ transplantation and
the use of human tissues and medical
research which is the subject of really
a whole nother symposium but what was so
exciting for us was that we were thrown
into those issues and given the
opportunity to help solve how do you
allow people to donate organs and
tissues and came up with the help of a
lot of others with a model law to do
that the uniform anatomical gift at
completed in 1968 we were having so much
fun we said to the secretary of HD w-who
of which NIH is a part can we stay on
for a third year and we signed up for
another year and they said our next
problem once you guys to look at is the
credentialing of these new health
practitioners that were just emerging as
Tom said in these very years we went to
Duke went to Colorado we went to Seattle
we met these wonderful innovative
physicians and nurses who were thinking
of new ways to practice medicine and as
Tom said intuitively it made great sense
to us that these people can do a great
job in healthcare we were not only
interested in the medical legal issues
but just the whole idea was very very
exciting I came to Yale after dr. Cole
who had been my favorite professor in
medical school and Philadelphia and
that's how I knew dr. Cole I came to
visit him one day in 1969 to just check
in as part of a site visit here an NIH
site visit and he said he'd been
following our career and I was sometimes
there's serendipity that if you're in
the right place at the right time you go
to the bathroom and they elect you
president of an association
and later it seems like a good idea i
mean out of at the time why i just
happened to notice that the article it
was in the New England Journal of
Medicine on organ transplantation was
sitting on his desk when I went in to
see him that day and I thought yes this
is great because Blair and I were
thinking at the time of okay this has
been wonderful where do we go next we'd
love to do some work in an academic
setting he suggested that we might like
to come to Yale and helped him run this
trauma program he came down to Bethesda
they didn't really know Blair as well
but the three of us at around for
breakfast in his hotel room over cold
scrambled eggs one morning and had
decided yes let's do this so we came
here to New Haven in nineteen seventy
July of 1970 to help him run the trauma
program but we said could we start a PA
program because we were so impressed and
he said sure see if you can fit it into
the trauma model you know so going
forward really there were two major foci
of our activities one was the emergency
medical system which again is the
subject of a whole nother symposium but
with the Yale School of Public Health
Sam Webb who was one of our colleagues
there nine graduate students in the
School of Public Health all of who were
working on this major study we ended up
doing which was to use the state of
Connecticut as our social laboratory
it's a small interstate you can do that
and see what's going on in ambulance
services what's going on in emergency
medicine there were no emergency
medicine doctors at the point at that
point ambulances were little station
wagons or in one case a hearse because
amber the 179 ambulance companies in the
state of Connecticut one was actually
owned and operated by a funeral director
now that is maybe not a very good
healthcare model but it's a great
business model
you either save them and make in charge
Medicare or if you can't you can work
out the funeral arrangements so that was
the state of emergency medicine there
was no 911 call and Blair's going to
refer to this in a minute a little bit
more of the work we did on that but
getting to the PA program and was here
thank you for being here in Paul mosin
was being hired by Jack and I've blaring
me as a guy our colleague he was the set
in the second class of dude graduates
and I'm very disappointed that he
couldn't be here with us today hello
Paul mosin thank you Paul mosin for the
video camera and so what we then had to
do was design a curriculum well we were
fortunate that we could base it on the
Duke model because Paul knew that
backwards and forwards and I had to kind
of peel them off me occasionally to say
well a Duke we did this and the Duke we
did that because I wanted to look at the
other models as well but we ended up
going around to the faculty here to
every department chairman to the Dean
and telling them here's what we're going
to do with your help if you're willing
to contribute with us universal support
from all these wonderful people at Yale
and as the Dean mentioned earlier this
is the kind of place that seems to be
willing to take chances and grow new
programs frankly they hadn't done much
out of the community before there is
more basic science bench research so dr.
Cole and this department of surgery was
really breaking new ground for Yale
Medical School more broadly we chose
five students to whom are here today
that you're going to hear about and hear
from in a little bit the selection
process was very important because we
wanted to get people who didn't want to
go to medical school and couldn't get in
we didn't wanted people who had had
previous health experience and aunts
going to talk more in detail about that
but choosing the right people who
willing to take a risk with us was very
very important as far as the the details
of writing the curriculum there's so
many stories we could tell about I just
got the high sign
he's been doing this to me for years I
forgot the umbrella with the hook sorry
I just got my butt we designed the
curriculum based on core principles as
we looked at physiology pathology
anatomy what are the core principles
that absolutely needed to know to be a
good job as a clinician let's not worry
so much about the esoteric diseases that
have been described in three people in
Taiwan you know as interesting as that
might be scientifically and the
professors seem to get this and seem to
be thrilled to work with us on that
choosing the students was very important
as I mentioned it was a little bit like
hit the jack you guys would really like
the jackie robinson's of the PA movement
here we wanted people to be crisp and
clean in their dress and are so our
people the four men and the one I don't
know about burnings dress code but as
well but the four men does Jim Brown
George Smith penny lorente dick Hall and
Burdine camp were first five coat and
tie please look crisp and clean when you
go to make rounds dick will tell some
great stories i'm sure beer dean well
later and why this was so important you
had to be on time you had to know your
stuff he had to do your homework
meanwhile in the evenings Paul mosin and
I and Anna Blair we're sitting down okay
we've got the curriculum for next week
done what
what about two weeks through now and the
other thing we got from our students was
feedback saying this is this class
didn't work so well you know could you
maybe next time do a little better or
this really did work well so we got a
lot of feedback from our students our
first graduating class graduated in
January of 73 and it was a thrill to
have dr. stead himself come up from Duke
and give us our first graduation address
it seems just like yesterday I'll stop
with that for now
and you are come on well actually I'm
sitting on a trapdoor and player says if
I don't leave enough time open well
Fred's already taken five of my minutes
she's going to take the other phone I
know well and I I told him I reassured
them then after Fred and I got through
with our little talks that we would need
a lawyer so all right before i start i
have to say how wonderful it is to see
all of you in rows like you used to be
when i was teaching and so many of you
come up said you know that stuff you
taught oil portable were true than we
thought it but I because I was teaching
him psychiatry but anyway and the other
thing I want to do is to recognize John
Cavanaugh was class of 74 came to us is
72 one of her earliest graduates and he
was the cynic wanna of what a PA
applicant was like it had a baffling
screwed he had a bachelor's degree of
sociology fair little science if you
have a little experience in emergency
medicine he became a student leader
class delegate to the AAA PA and went on
then to do some work after Kenneth PA in
the emergency medicine and then got his
MBA got a PhD he now is at the College
of Osteopathy osteopathic medicine at
Philadelphia in and he's a tenured
professor there and share of PA program
there now the end that's not the end of
story though but six weeks ago I get
this little thing in the mail and it's a
digital recording of a taped interview
that he had converted to digital that he
did with me in 1976
so I hope he doesn't mind my using some
of my own words which I'm always so used
to having to eat today now i have three
talking points and thank you again
Johnny wonderful i told him in a note I
wrote back that someone had really
raised a good son oh well again I've
three talking points one is philanthropy
the 3 p's politics and puberty so you'll
have to bear with me to begin to the
little terms of philanthropy there is a
story behind that Commonwealth grant
that Jack Cole got which i think is
worth telling it illuminates the last
halcyon days of foundations private
giving before the Tax Reform Act of 1970
to change the way foundations gave money
second of all and you alluded to there's
an irony of getting money from the
Commonwealth one that gets to that later
now Charlie Brown's dog Snoopy always
starts his stories with twas a dark and
stormy night
well when Jekyll went down to see would
Newton's there's another commonwealth
fund at the Harkness mansion
seventy-second Street in the Fifth
Avenue it was a dark and stormy day so
Jack hole and quick Newton were sitting
around front of a roaring fire sipping
tea and later in the day I think sherry
and I both of them consummate gentleman
and the jack had two proposals that he
needed money for one was the trauma
manpower and emergency services the
other was for a lab building for a obgyn
research and he had that the programs
and requested all being submitted and
right in the very capable staff there
had vetted both of his ideas and quick
newt was very receptive Jack's asked was
for 750 thousand dollars over two years
quick Newton said well we're very
interested what you want to do you're
not going to be able to do it for some
150 thousand dollars so he got him by
the arm assured him into an empty
conference room gingham pencil and his
budget back and said take 30 minutes and
go figure yeah cold did came out said
well I it's a million now a quick Newton
looked at hope he said now tell you what
we're going to do we're going to give
you a million for the health manpower
emergency systems and we're going to
match up with a million for a building
Jack Cole flabbergasted but quiz Newton
explained he said we want people to have
enough money for their projects for them
to succeed we do not want them to fall
short for lack of cash and after a fair
amount of experience we know what these
programs takes for money and how long
they take him by the way you say you're
going to get it done in three years try
five we be happening to us right
actually it's a Katzenjammer kids here
Hans and Fritz
it was done in little over two but
nonetheless so that's that was how that
came to be now this that grant of a
million dollars plus the million for
Gregory is probably the last of its size
from a private foundation because within
months the tax reform bill I talked
about changed right giving grants became
like federal grants they had to be line
item for excruciating Lee specific
purposes pre-assigned staff for a limit
of three years and there was no longer
Foundation funds of any time for bricks
and mortar another point in telling the
story is the irony the Fred referred to
that today or yesterday we sat in the
Harkness auditorium to celebrate the
begin the celebration of the PA program
founded 40 years four years ago at the
Harkness mansion in New York now for
politics when Princeton University
President Woodrow Wilson ran for
president of the United States he was
scoffed at and ridiculed why the man has
no experience in politics he said ivory
tower academic to which he replied
anyone was ever taught on a faculty of a
college or gone through the indignities
of the tenure process or run a college
cannot say such an outlandish thing knew
plenty of our politics and alas it's
true of Yale there are four things of
questions that I've always that in the
beginning I've asked myself over time
that gotten answered one is how did the
PA program very survival next one is how
what led the medical school to accept it
adopted went to school a nursing thing
very venerable decades-old institution
with its own masters program for non
nurse college graduates who want to
become nurses so and then finally that's
also really do how do we change from a
surgical assistant how can port on a
certain system for regular type a PA
program well now the answers to these
questions require a little bit of
background and understand about the Yale
ethos and culture yale university is all
about its undergraduate 5,500 students
period it's not about its graduate now
except your suspect for the law school
after i'll give the country presidents
vice presidents the governor's senators
at the state and the national level and
representative statement gives us mayors
of big cities and then there have a
smallish ph.d program which is fairly
rigorous and that deserves that has some
distinction to it but it depends a
school if we live in a secular age we
need we're ministers the forestry school
we need more forest rangers the drama
school just a lot of adults playing
make-believe the medical school however
it had to float on its own bottom and it
generates income from two sources one
from the faculty practice which goes
back some of the tub medical school but
some of it goes back downtown and the
grants that gets
wh-which have 67% overheads doing so
some of that money gets sent downtown
now downtown the euphemism for this
central Yale undergraduate or attempted
place it's so hard for people coming
from the outside and get this so i was
astounded when you know we went into a
suit oh boy now none of Yale's graduate
schools therefore is a tale which wags
downtown's door and it's for nothing not
for nothing that yells mascot is a
bulldog so keeping all of this in mind
how in the world could pa pa program
here survive and the tandem questions
were prompted the medical schools were
supported and what about nurse the
medical school had for years enjoyed
government grants for HW in the early
90s however atw is pressing schools like
Yale and primary care residences or
family residence kingman brewster then
president of Yale said never and quote a
medical school Nevermore as well they on
the basis that they returned position
scientists and specialists become deans
of school medicine all over the country
chair departments in schools events and
to chair sections hospitals in the face
our
usual oh I know this thing is here okay
so endearing you threaten to pull off on
the medical school now rooster 10 we
have a physician associate program which
has a system that dodged a gwm federal
boy further Brewster said that the newly
co educated undergraduates but the PA
program provided those undergraduate
three females an opportunity for a
career in medicine other than nursing
and but in the mid to late 70s funding
was drawing down from the feds for the
PA program and PA tuition had been
instituted got to be about nine thousand
dollars for student got to be about nine
thousand dollars per student and the
bean counters crosstown downtown with
their green eyeshades and arm garters
said yeah but it's costing 20,000 to
educate it so what were they going to do
about the shortfall of eleven thousand
dollars well you could charge more
tuition you could institute some
economies now to take care of part of it
but there's still about a five thousand
dollar shortfall well the medical school
is going to have to cover that and also
we get into charging tuition then you
are more institutionalized and you
become under more scrutiny from downtown
so Charles Taylor the Provost at the
time and it's Provost's who run
universities there the they are the top
bean counter so Charles Taylor appointed
the selection committee to consider the
fate of the lpa program representatives
from Provence off is the medical school
the PA medical director not Paul mosin
who is the program director
and school of nursing and the hospital
we're all on the selection committee
they worked very hard for months and
they interviewed a lot of people that
got a lot of information their task was
to really explore the whole concept as
well as its costs and come up with some
kind of option for the future now these
are some of the things that considered
the Yale Medical School faculty we're
having a problem because they were
teaching pas pharmacology on Tuesdays
and the nursing school pharmacology and
Wednesdays it wouldn't be nice to just
teach both of them on Thursday once and
so there was some talk of perhaps having
the didactic the PAS shared with the
School of Nursing perhaps the whole
didactic could be farmed out to
Quinnipiac University perhaps the whole
program could go to public health
perhaps it could become a hospital
medical center PA program or they could
move to a master's program or keep the
basic certificate program then there was
always the final search the final
solution is that when you have a funded
program that where the money dries up
you place the program into a burlap sack
like a litter of unwanted kittens and
drowning so salix every report came out
and said that they favored keeping the
program certificate with the option of
maybe considering masters the report
sent downtown to the Provost's office
and to kingman brewster with at the last
minute and without the knowledge of
committee a minority report from the
School of Nursing now the tone of it was
gazing they said the PA program was
really just vocational not an academic
program why the program did not even
formally require a bachelor's degree and
you could take in those Hospital trained
nurses and that the screening process
the application process nobody from
downtown in the bottom line in a final
scold the minority report said that Yale
downtown should be ashamed of itself a
party to such a program well the people
on the committee I mean there were
people who might have sympathized with
some of the points that school of
nursing was making but as members the
committee who had worked so hard they
were less than enchanted with the way
that this minority report got submitted
so there was some nursing school kind of
lost a little bit of goodwill
now nursing I know she's now nursing had
not yet developed at Yale their nurse
practitioner or nurse clinician program
so with all this PA thing they got
caught behind the curve and flat-footed
to be able to say we provide primary
care now finally how did the surgical
associate surgical assistant worth into
a physician associate Wow dr. Cole was a
great delegator had hired paul mozem an
ex-military quran second class at Duke
to come on board and to start a PA
program but this was a little bit before
i started jan-paul started in march the
twins were busy doing their service for
the country in Washington it couldn't
get here till july by the time they got
here famsa was a little energizer bunny
he had been going around to the
faculties ranging possible courses
arranged in clinical so that thing was
pretty well going down the road and he
kind of went to Jack colon said you know
I was hired here to do a do PA first
class program I don't know surgical
assistant so by that time though Paul
had recruiting going on applications
coming in in a class to start january
first of 1973 and another one
so that was that now we're getting
puberty it's going to take me about two
minutes for those of you who remember my
course in psychosexual levels of
development you will understand my
framing the development of the PA
profession here at Yale and elsewhere
and I it began as a brainchild of dr.
stead and Felmy Engels at Duke and they
actually had nurse practitioner program
called such and in the 60s they had met
four or five classes of them they tried
twice and they went to the National
League of Nursing to be accredited he
got turned down the first time second
time ug instead said well what can we do
and they said nothing we will never
accredit you nurses don't practice
medicine so he was done then with nurses
so that brainchild of theirs proved to
be a miscarriage a PA concept however
using ex-military corpsman then was
berthed at do and then in its infancy PA
programs took tentative steps into a
world beyond Duke and the Duke graduates
of course we demand to run those
programs so dude was big brother to a
growing number of siblings then the PA
concept went into a latency period of
intense study and learning about it by
the foundations and the feds before
proceeding ahead with more little ones
the nascent Yale PA program produced its
white paper which moved the concept into
its puberty always gender-neutral PA
program here the effect of Yale's
program was androgynous on the one hand
Yale put hair on the professions chest
on the other hand it helped make the PA
profession a thing of beauty so alluring
that agw could not keep its eyes off it
and kept slipping up big money as the
price for their enchantment eventually
even Yale who had once been anxious and
uncertain about the future pas became
smitten with the profession then grew
into young adulthood a stage of
development marked by the pursuit of
dreams the PA profession here has become
more than the foundations the government
or Yale ever dreamt now at age 40 the
Yale program is in mature midlife and at
the peak of its productivity beware
please no midlife crises for my static
can you hear me all right okay so since
as predicted I have no time I can't even
tell some of my extraordinary jokes you
know and Mary's having a heart attack so
I did want to say though it is really
special to be back on a panel with my
vastly older twin brother he's not very
bright but he's one of the best-looking
guys I've ever seen a couple of things
that I would just build on i'm really
going to talk about three things and
this is going to feel like a drink of
water from a fire hose so sort of strap
in seatbelts car seats helmets the whole
deal one is a little bit about the legal
climate and tom has sort of set the
stage for that and what did we do
secondly a little bit of more about the
white paper in the book and the five
foundations and then close with the
emergency care contagion and how we took
the work in Connecticut and spread it
nationally okay so obviously in terms of
the legal background and the political
climate was a time of tremendous turmoil
change rapidity sort of Mach speed and
enormous divisive pneus I mean
the battle between organized medicine
and organized nursing was a religious
war and it was over what we came to
conclude the wrong question it was a
frame the fundamental framing question
is we have our body of knowledge and you
have your body of knowledge and we
control ours it's called medicine and
you control your so-called nursing and
so that independence in that battle
which had a long history was front and
center of the legal environment so based
on the all the things that Tom talked
about the Declaration of legal
dependence we called in the book that
the pas Magna Carta because it was core
to the quick lift off and the quick
spread had the PA movement taken a
similar tack and tried to define their
own body of knowledge that they
controlled there would probably not have
been more than one or two pilot PA
programs in the United States and they
would have closed my prediction in three
to five years and the movement would
never have occurred it was that that
important because of all things that Tom
outline that were going on concurrently
so the simplest thing that we learned
with Duke and we had gotten to know them
well as Fred said in the HTW people and
they had a wonderful task force about
should they verify legally codify the
physicians right to delegate through
them at the practice act or should they
have prior pool of training programs
which often could take a lot of time as
Tom outline or submit a job description
to the Medical Board of the state which
at this point did not even have that
role that's they weren't set up to do
that it was they were only on doctors
and so the simplest route to Rome to get
this thing started was the delegation
amendment and we could write it in one
paragraph i talked about diagnosed treat
operate and prescribe for Holy Grail
what medicine was and said that
basically pas could do anything that the
doctor delegated to them as long as they
were under their supervision
control and responsibility thus there
was of the three that was the trike sort
of the caveat that there would be
protection so we worked with somebody
you may have heard of named joe
lieberman he was a 30 year one year old
state senator and we and others and we
got that bill it through the Connecticut
legislature signed by Governor Tom
mescal in 71 because the time pressure
was simply enormous the burdens of the
world we're beating down the door saying
I got to have some legal authority to do
what you guys are asking me to do so
that was how we handled the legal thing
knowing that that was a short term it
was part of this larger tapestry of
approval and accreditation the book the
chronology of how that happened a little
bit more Vernon Lepard is another key
player whose name has not been mentioned
this morning and he was the Dean prior
to the current Dean at Yale the Dean was
the Dean men and he was doing some
consulting work with the macy foundation
in new york and a consortium of five
foundations commonwealth carnegie
rockefeller Macy and the child
development had been meeting regularly
on what should they which it the next
chapter be in the PA new health
practitioner movement they were the
pioneers as you've heard they were early
funders of some of the first programs
Duke Colorado MedX along with the feds
what was the next chapter what were the
next big policy issue so they asked us
the three of us to do at first sort of
an environmental scan how do you see
this is the sort of the 20,000 foot
policy book was an academic curriculum
review and then what's your crystal ball
say are the implications from going from
the very first phase of innovation to
the second phase if you think of a
bell-shaped curve of innovation the
early adopter phase which
were now in what other major things we
need to be worrying about and then give
us a set of specific concrete
recommendations for foundations and the
feds to fund and so that was what the
white paper did or attempted to do we
were very fortunate that we had all
these wonderful relationships we
developed in our last year at hgw so
when we'd call somebody they return our
phone call and we really went to work
and they felt sufficiently good about it
that they said you got to publish this
thing in the first was with the
University Press so that's how that
happened and then the third thing I
wanted to talk to you about was back and
moving back to the larger trauma EMS
world Fred's already set the stage that
it really wasn't part of the healthcare
system at the time for the reasons he
covered and many others but it was under
this rapid change from the Vietnam
experience so we shared a Advisory
Committee in the state of Connecticut
that had the physician leaders and nurse
leaders the fire chiefs I think the
hospital people wanted was the
funeral-home director and came up with a
blueprint for improving trauma number
and secure the state of Connecticut and
that's when we use the nine
extraordinary graduate students that
Fred mentioned in the School of Public
Health each of whom wrote their master's
thesis and a component of it and that
rolled up into that report one of which
was to promote the whole pre-hospital
system you've already heard was
basically a wasteland and all this other
concurrent stuff that was going on at
Mach speed out of the Academy and the
College of Surgeons so when you made a
phone call in America at this time you
could get someone who knew how to
respond to a fire or a criminal event
but if you had a poisoning or giving
birth they had no training that
dispatcher that first response plus
there was no 911 so you call different
people and in Hartford you literally had
ambulance companies fighting over whose
patient it was that that is how archaic
it was at the time so we had a lot of
recommendations try and change all that
and the other serendipity that occurred
was we then Fred night and went from
here in 73 July of 73 down the turnpike
to a place called the Robert Wood
Johnson Foundation and it was brand new
Robert Wood Johnson swill had been
probated and it was they had 55 million
dollars a year to give away that was a
very big number was the second biggest
foundation after Ford overnight and it
was all in health care the will said
improve health care in the United States
so he can do anything the other thing
that Dave Rogers who was the first
president having coming up from Johns
Hopkins as Dean said with that early
team let's look at a whole way of doing
business as a foundation part of it was
the accountability that Anne mentioned
but part of it was being proactive not
just reactive so every foundation had
its little Butch and said here our
priorities were interested in these
three things and people would apply and
the grants would come in applications
over the transom and you'd look at them
and make some decisions kind of
everything was a one-off with a few
exceptions like the clinical Scholars
Program something that had a core
strategy this idea was radically
different which was taken area in which
you could make a surgical focused
targeted intervention like the changing
world of emergency care and get the best
minds in the country and come up with a
national program very top-down very
strategic not bottom up not lays a fair
and put out some money so I had the
privilege fred was working on manpower
issues a lot at the foundation to help
lead the first national program that the
Robert Wood Johnson Foundation ever did
which was around emergency medical
systems and we got a great advisory
committee of top people the we
contracted out the management of the
program rather hiring a big staff in
Princeton in this case to the National
sciences who actually ran it 15 million
dollars 40 for grants 32 states site
visits a technical assistance arm to
help the grantee some of whom were fire
departments some of whom were county
government some of them were hospitals
was a really an eclectic group evaluated
by the rand corporation in terms of
impact of these interventions them what
did the money go for training front line
people in the field getting the radios
and connecting the dots getting how
training dispatchers all of which the
course had now come out from the academy
okay so there was a curricula for all of
this that didn't exist two years before
and finally trying to evaluate the
impact access to care the speed of which
it took to get to the scene to be able
to communicate at the scene back to the
hospital ER and then get into the right
trauma system which were just being
developed from go to scoop and haul take
to the nearest hospital no go to a
selected place it's actually a
designated trauma system and so what was
particularly nice about that was that
david boyd in closing was a leading
trauma surgeon at the time ran the
illinois program was on that our tbj
advisory committee he went down to hgw
and to run their whole big trauma system
so are 15 million dollars leveraged 255
million dollars of grants to do
virtually the same thing which made the
evaluation a [ __ ] because you know some
people who didn't make it in our
sweepstakes actually got more money from
david but that was all right the point
is everyone got better you know the tide
raised all boats and it was a very
exciting time so in the three minutes
that I had thank you very much thank you
Mary I just wanted to give you a glimpse
from my perspective thanks very much
appreciated